les murs de la paix brûle de nouveau en
irlande du nord
cette barrière symbolique qui sépare les
communautés catholique et protestante
semble actuellement bien fragile depuis
le 29 mars
des émeutes éclatent sporadiquement dans
la province britannique
principalement dans le camp unioniste
protestant et fidèles à la couronne
britannique
des adolescents certains à peine âgée
d'une douzaine d'années armé de briques
de barres de fer et de cocktails molotov
défient les forces de l'ordre en une
semaine deux heures au moins 55
policiers ont été blessés washington
dublin et londres appelle au calme
je suis profondément préoccupé par ces
scènes de violence en irlande du nord en
particulier les attaques contre la
police qui protège le public et les
entreprises ou encore ces agression
contre un chauffeur de bus ou un
journaliste le moyen de résoudre les
différends passe par le dialogue
non pas par la violence ou la
criminalité
pas de quoi apaiser les protestataires
qui se sentent trahis par londres en
cause le break site qui réveille de
vieux démons
le retour des contrôles douaniers aux
frontières de la province crispe les
unionistes qui se sentent dépossédés de
leur identité britannique du fait de
cette frontière ni ouverte ni fermée
avec le royaume uni se crée un sentiment
de mise à l'écart qu'à tenter de balayer
le secrétaire d'état pour l'irlande du
nord
nous reconnaissons les problématiques
d'identité et nous sommes en train de
travailler à ce que les citoyens
britanniques d'irlande du nord vivent de
la même façon que les citoyens
britanniques résidant en grande-bretagne
une crise identitaire qui réveille le
spectre des 30 ans de guerre entre
protestants unionistes et catholiques
républicains partisans d'une irlande
réunifiée
alors que cette frontière encore fragile
entre irlande du nord et du sud semble
mise à mal elle ne sera sans doute pas
la dernière à être mise à l'épreuve
suite au bris exit au sein d'un royaume
pas très uni ces jours ci